[Music]
foreign
good morning and welcome to Sophia Ridge
on Sunday get brexit done that favorite
Boris Johnson phase phrase and now
something that Rishi Cenac has again
promised today will a deal with the EU
could come as soon as tomorrow but
getting it over the line with the
cabinet the dup and eurosceptic
conservatives won't be easy what would
you see next says he will get brexit
done but if you haven't been living
under a cave for the last few years
you'll know that he's not the first
concert to pm to make that promise and
if you can't at what cost for his own
political future we've got a pack show
and lots to ask our guests this morning
on the program today we're going to be
hearing from the Deputy Prime Minister
and Justice secretary Dominic RAV and
for labor we'll be talking to you the
shadow foreign secretary David Lammy
we'll also be joined by Mark Francois
the chair of the conservative you're a
skeptic and peace group The ERG they'll
have a big say in the brexit deal also
today the Scottish Health secretary are
hoping to replace Nicholas sturgeon as
first Minister Hamza Yusuf and the
General Secretary of the National
Education Union as those teachers
strikes Loom Dr Mary bastet will be on
the show
plus we've got an absolutely fascinating
interview with the former U.S
presidential candidate Senator Bernie
Sanders
[Music]
hello good morning well let's start this
morning shall we hearing from the
government on what could be a pivotal
day for Rishi Cena as that deal over
Northern Ireland gets ever closer a
little earlier I spoke to his Deputy
Prime Minister and Justice secretary
Dominic Robb
what is going on with brexit how close
are we to a deal well look we've clearly
made some progress in recent weeks and
days and it's really important to get
this fixed we know that the Northern
Ireland protocol has created real
challenges for businesses across all
communities Northern Ireland is posing a
challenge to the Good Friday agreement
and in fact the Integrity of the UK so I
think the Prime Minister the foreign
secretary in the online sector have been
hard at it and if we can make some of
those changes which we've been pushing
for to get a shift away for example in
trade in goods from GB from Britain to
Northern Ireland from having checks and
declarations on individual Consignments
towards a more intelligence-based
approach to controls if we can encourage
the EU to rely more on Market
surveillance than those checks Market
surveillance particularly in the
Republic to protect the EU single Market
that would if we can get that kind of
deal across the line Mark a paradigm
shift in the approach and will be very
good news to the community's Northern
Ireland and I think for the Good Friday
agreement as well so you said that
there's been progress in weeks and days
it's effectively there right are we
talking about Monday could it be as soon
as tomorrow well you and I have been
discussing brexit for years now and uh
we always say there's no deal until
you've got the whole deal so I don't
want to get ahead of ourselves but is
that is that is
real progress we want to make sure all
the pieces are in place but I think uh
hopefully there'll be good news uh in a
matter of days not not weeks and again
as I say this would be critically
important it'll be a major achievement
by this prime minister and all those
involved but also Mark paid tribute to
the efforts of those that went before
but if we can get this resolved for the
people of Northern Ireland for the
businesses for the communities and
frankly uh the manifesto place we made
really to thoroughly properly fully get
brexit done to be a major achievement
um now there's obviously lots of
speculation going on about what's in the
deal can you give us a bit of a sense I
mean you've already sort of touched on a
few things there are we talking about
like a green light system for example
the goods that are going to remain in
Northern Ireland and then a red light
system for one sort of go to the EU is
that right look I think the trading
goods between Britain and Northern
Ireland is critical and if we can get
away from Individual checks in the
northern Irish reports and points of
arrival and encourage more of an
intelligence based approach so is the
green light red is that is that roughly
the right area those are the kinds of
things I mean it's well known uh that
we've been pushing for and again
encouraging the EU to look at Market
surveillance which basically means where
they're worried about Goods arriving in
Northern Ireland then going into the
rest of the EU including the Republic of
Ireland and posing a threat to the
single Market they keep an eye on that
they monitor that through the stores the
shops in the Republic and the rest of
the EU how about the role of the ecj the
European court of justice this is a big
red line isn't it for some people in
your own party and also the DP well look
there's a number of other things and I
can't divulge all the detail not least
because we want to make sure we get the
whole deal done but what I would say is
if we can scale back some of the
regulatory checks that apply and some of
the paperwork that applies that would in
itself involve a significant a
substantial scaling back of the role of
the ecga and of course Sophie the other
thing you'll know is this sense that in
the irreducible core areas where the EU
insists that EU uh need to apply to
protect the Integrity of the single
Market we need to make sure there are
any new rules in the future there's a
proper Democratic check and a proper
Democratic check coming out of the
institutions in Stormont that's
interesting so basically there are new
EU rules that there should be a way for
Northern Ireland to have it say in a way
over the rules that can affect them well
that must be right in any Democratic
Arrangement and certainly in relation to
that I think we would envisage that that
check would be the last word will be
with the Democratic institutions
obviously the UK government would have a
role and there will be no role for the
ecj and something like that now you said
that me and you spoke about brexit
before we have for years right like
anyone else in Westminster and I have to
say you know you guys obviously think
that you've got some significant
concessions out of the EU but this is
about politics as well isn't it and I
just wonder is there an accusation that
Rishi sunic has been a bit politically
naive not getting the DP on side already
not getting the European research group
if you're a skeptic conservatives on
side as was well these are the people
you need here to get anything over the
line well look I was brexit secretary
back in 2018. I watched it the one thing
I'd say is you've got to be very careful
uh to bring people on board at the right
stage not to divulge the details not to
have if you like pressure tactics on all
sides and I'd say that without aspersion
on anyone
um what what the Prime Minister and the
government would be judged by is what we
deliver and you're not going to deliver
unless you get people on side you say
that you don't want to divulge the
details but look we know how this ends
ask Theresa May you can think you've got
a great deal let's see if the dep don't
come on side let's see Mike you're
living under a cave you know you must
know how these things work no I think
what Rishi uh and it was cleverly and
Christine Harris have done is very
quietly but doggedly pursue the changes
we need that will have our hope I
believe the support of people going
forward and it will be a massive
achievement if we can get that deal over
line but frankly the the media
speculation you're doing your job safely
understand it but Rishi sudak has
written in the Sunday news papers
talking about the deal hasn't he and
he's been very careful to set up the
objectives but also that we uh we're not
there yet
um but we're obviously in a position
where uh we're close to on the cusp of a
deal and I think if we can get that deal
over the line you think you can are you
confident I'm reasonably confident we
won't be talking about it if we didn't
think that there was a good momentum
some pragmatism that we haven't seen
before from the EU side but we've got to
get all the pieces in place but it would
Mark A a great deal for Northern Ireland
would protect the Integrity of the
United Kingdom and we would fulfill our
Manifesto will there be a vote will
there be a vote on the deal in house
Commons Luca let me allow the government
to set all of the details out in uh in
the proper way
um but I think uh inevitably Parliament
will find a way to have it say
that doesn't sound to me like you are
going to hold a boat no I'm going to
just I what I don't want to do Sophie is
divorce the details bit by bit drip drip
um but Parliament I mean it doesn't
sound like you want to answer that
question if there's going to be a vote
give you a sense of the direction of
travel
um but of course we've got to get the
deal at the international level signed
uh and and agreed and make sure that the
arrangements that underpin it are to the
extent that they would require
legislation they would have to go
through the House of Commons
isn't a vote on the deal they'll be
uproar on your benches back there we
want to handle this properly
um and uh and you know and in the right
way and I think one thing we've learned
with meaningful votes and various other
things since
um uh 2016 and Beyond is that you have
to carry part with you and I'm confident
we would be able to okay I just can't
use a land over the weekend that the
eu's Ashley Wonderland was to meet with
King Charles yesterday
now that didn't happen for operational
reasons we're told but can you see how
you know right as brexit negotiations
come to a head that could be seen as
dragging the monarchy into politics but
the the the the king the Monarch
regularly meets heads of states and
heads of leading international
organizations
um the precise timing of it and the
scheduling it actually is for the palace
and for the monarchy to decide it's not
something that we would impinge on but
look the um but it's actually a pretty
uh part of the normal functions of the
king would be to meet senior
International figures okay I want to
talk to to you a little bit about Boris
Johnson yeah he told Sky News this week
that the best way forward was his
Northern Ireland's protocol bill has he
been lobbying against this deal
he has not been me against this deal but
look I would pay tribute to what Boris
did in relation to the ni legislation
because I do think it is reinforced our
hand in these negotiations the
government's position was under Boris
but also under which is an act that in
the last resort we would be willing to
unilaterally legislate
um and I think that's helped I would
also say having been involved in both
governments that that pushing through
the legislation you'll actually route a
deal with the EU was fraught with legal
uncertainty
um because ultimately we'd be legally
challenged including an arbitration
including arbitration under the deal
that Boris and and previous governments
this is interesting isn't it because as
you say the Northern Ireland protocol
Bill effectively allows you to
unilaterally override in emergencies
yeah parts of the of the deal do you
think that would have been challenging
the courts effectively the ecj having a
role in it well I think inevitably it
would be legally challenged I think
actually this should have been the
arbitral tribunal if we go into
arbitration on that and and then you
don't know what the outcome would be you
could get fined you could win you could
win some of it not all of it so it is
definitely and I think successful
governments have taken the view that
actually and that's why Boris didn't
press forward right the way through with
the legislation at the time
um and the the ideal outcome is to get a
negotiated solution but but also I want
to be clear I think the legislation
having the legislation there ready to go
reinforce the negotiators hands and I
think it was important but now time to
move on from it
well look if you get a negotiated
solution you don't need to proceed with
the legislation unilaterally okay now
I've done an awful lot about brexit um
litigation for alleged bullying of civil
servants do you have any idea when the
findings of that investigation are going
to be due
well first of all Sophie as you know
I've said that I behave professionally
throughout but I also when the
complaints were made called for an
independent inquiry the Prime Minister
set one up it is for the independent
investigator Adam Tolley Casey to decide
all of that and I won't comment on it
further precisely because I want to
professionally respect the Integrity of
that process I understand of course that
you feel that you don't want to
Prejudice the outcome of the
investigation we of course won't get
into details of it for the same reason
but I just want to ask a couple of very
fast actual straightforward questions on
the timeline when were you first aware
that a complaint had been made
so we I've already said this to the
House of Commons the first time any
complaint was
I was notified was the day before in the
mid-november when the day before I did
pmqs because the times reported that the
first formal complaint was actually made
last March is that right so uh not to my
knowledge but Sophie I'm going to be
really careful about this uh I've said
to Adam tolly I've said I'm not going to
comment on it and I wanted to give you a
straight answer to a straight question
I'm not going to start getting into the
he said she said of the inquiry it's not
right for me to do so when was the first
conversation you had with Rishi sunak
about it
um I honestly can't remember but it
would not have been uh until the formal
complaint was made in mid-november so
that was after you were appointed to the
cabinet under Russia yes
um even though there is this letter at
the times has seen that suggests that
the first formal complaint was made last
March well look again not to your
knowledge what you're doing is inviting
me to comment on uh the what is actually
part of the subject matter of the
inquiry and I'm not going to do just the
timeline but I'm trying again I know but
it but it inevitably drags me into that
and look the uh Adam Tully will conduct
this inquiry he's it's already obviously
ongoing and I'll answer as I said I
would all questions he's got and
there'll be a transparent report but
don't please don't um uh expect me to
answer questions now it wouldn't be
right for me to do so Jake Perry the
former chairman says you should stand
down while that investigation's ongoing
why haven't you done that well look I
think um well first of all that's
ultimately for the prime minister to
decide but I think actually just by
lodging complaints you can knock out a
cabinet minister or senior figure I'm
not sure that's right we believe in
innocent or proven guilty in this
country and uh look I'll cooperate fully
with the inquiry and I'll respect the
outcome of it I don't think it's
knocking out though is it we're talking
about standing aside while some very
serious allegations by multiple people
are being investigated well if you
believe in innocence or proven guilty
you wouldn't want uh to penalize people
until you've got the outcome and I could
see why that would politicize the
process of lodging complaints because
you can effectively for months on end
get remove cabinet members or other
leading political figures if the
complaint is that Powerball will you
resign I'm not going to start
speculating on what the outcome might be
again you're asking me to comment on the
subject matter I'm not asking you to
come up with a project myself I'm asking
you to find out what what you will do
but it's a hypothetical question so I've
got two different outcomes well
allow me to respond in the right uh way
at the right time of course look if an
allegation of bullying is upheld I would
resign okay thank you uh right now let's
talk a little bit about the brief that
you uh are continuing with Ministry of
Justice uh brief so you're announcing
today that transgender women who've
committed violent or sexual offenses
will no longer be able to be held in
mainstream women's prisons talk to me
about that announcement and what should
I do well we want to have a liberal
sensitive tolerant approach to the LGBT
community as a whole and in particular
trans uh the trans Community who suffer
a lot in this country and have high
levels of challenges for example mental
health bullying and things like that so
I want to be clear about that um equally
we need to protect the most vulnerable
in our society and I think where you've
got uh trans offenders trans women
offenders and the suggestion is or the
question is whether they move into the
uh the female prisoner State I think we
need need to be really clear about
protecting the other female offenders
prisoners in that estate so we're very
clear that from next week we will
introduce new rules which means that any
trans offender with male Jenner Taylor
intact or who have been convicted of a
sexual offense and I'm adding to that if
they've been convicted of a violent
offense there will not be allowed into
the female prison estate now this comes
after the case of Isla Bryson and
Scotland who's a trans woman convicted
of two rapes
is Isle of Brighton a man or a woman
look I I think it's
um very clear that she's not a woman in
the sense that I've defined it but
that's for the Scottish authorities in
this in the English and Welsh prison
State she would not be allowed into the
female estate by the way just one point
of correction I introduced these changes
a while ago the reason they're coming
into force uh on Monday is because the
time taken to do it very carefully and
assiduously and I want to talk a little
bit about the course backlog as well
sure this is a huge huge issue under
your department and it was causing
frankly misery for you know so many
people who are waiting and unacceptably
long amount of time to have their
Justice heard and I think we can have a
quick look at the number of defendants
uh awaiting uh trial this is the backlog
the number of people waiting for
unsentencing and you can see it's
effectively flatlining increasing
slightly it's certainly not coming down
and for the first time rape victims are
now facing a typical delay of more than
three years for their case to become
completed in court this is the rape case
waiting time which to be honest I find
quite extraordinary uh really how is
this in any way acceptable so on three
points first of all actually the we were
getting the backlog down of course the
backlog was caused by the pandemic
because the uh the rules meant that you
couldn't have jury trials uh because the
social distancing rules it's not it's
not coming down though isn't it hold on
so it was starting to come down we made
great progress then we had the CBA
strike it went back up it is now
stabilizing and coming down not as fast
as I would have liked it which is why
we're working with the courts we've
reviewed and renewed the Nightingale
courts look at the backlog again please
just to get that graph up again if
possible the latest data it's not coming
down it is so not by a huge amount yet
but actually if you look at this these
are the MOJ figures can you just explain
to me am I being really stupid here
because it doesn't look like it's coming
down well actually I think if you look
at the December versus the November
figure uh we've gone right
yeah we've gone past the peak it is
starting to stabilize it's coming down
uh not by uh enough and that's why we're
taking all the other measures that I
refer to with the Nightingale courts
with the removal of the uh limit on
sitting days
and in relation to rape
um you're absolutely right that those
cases are particularly challenging in
fact I can tell you that we've seen uh
almost a doubling since 2019 but
actually the progress has been more
recent as well since 2019 we've seen a
doubling of the number of cases what is
the number sorry let me let me tell you
but just because I've seen this before
the doubling of rape cases and that's
what I said um let me answer the
question because this is so sensitive
and it's so important okay we've doubled
the number of cases referred uh to by
the police the CPS we've also seen a
doubling of the number of CPS charges
and they're doubling also of the Crown
Court receipts in the last year alone
great convictions the volume have gone
up by two-thirds and can we talk numbers
because I think the the problem is if
you say the doubling it sounds oh wow
that's great but if you're doubling from
like 0.9 to 1.8 of rape uh reports
ending a conviction then that's hardly
any is it well actually the conviction
rate I think it's gone up to
um 69 but you have to be careful the
conviction rate was properly by the CPS
is measured cases that come to court and
that result in a conviction but look
we're Restless to do more so if I don't
want to give you false impression we
want to do much much more which is why I
introduced 24 7 rape support line which
is why I'm quadrupling the support for
victims compared to 2010 when labor will
ask in office we've got this operation
Superior prosecutors and police
operating much more uh hand in glove
together and I also introduced section
28 pre-recorded uh uh evidence for the
victims the complainants in rape cases
so that they can do so without the glare
of a courtroom we're making progress but
there is still much much more to do yeah
and my understanding is I think it's
still if you report a rape chance of
using you know a conviction is still I
think less than two percent and I would
also just go back to the original
question is it acceptable that a typical
rape case is now you have to wait three
years for that to come to trial well no
we want to get that number down clearly
and critically uh if you come forward
and of course it's incredibly difficult
not just to be the victim but then to
come and face the whole process of the
criminal justice system and what we want
to do is encourage victims and
complaints to stay with the process the
two big things is the expansion of
independent uh sexual violence advisors
and we know that we've got a much better
chance of securing convictions if the
victims get that support early and the
24 7 rape support line also means they
get the right support as early as
possible we've got much more to do but
again I come back to the key thing which
is over the last year the volume of
convictions has risen by two-thirds more
to do but we're heading back in the
right direction after covert okay thank
you very much
Dominic Robb uh speaking there well
let's get the view from labor now at
shall we we can talk to the party Shadow
from secretary David Lammy thank you
very much for being on the program this
morning Mr Lammy and so we just heard
from Dominic Robb there saying that
there's been real progress on a brexit
deal that he's hateful it will come in a
matter of days rather than weeks
um if that does get over the line will
you back it
look yes I think that labor is
determined to act in the national
interests of our country and of Northern
Ireland it's very likely that if a deal
does emerge it will be an improvement on
the Northern Ireland protocol deal that
was struck by Boris Johnson just a few
years ago and deal with the issues of
goods and services uh particularly
trafficking from the United Kingdom into
Northern Ireland and then into the
Republic of Ireland and for that reason
we have indicated that we expect to
support this deal when it emerges I
suspect in the next few days
we've got a bit of detail on what we
expect it to be from Dominic Robb as the
kind of red light green light system
depending on whether goods are going to
stay in Northern Ireland or go to the EU
um do you ever she's like a bit of
credit for getting the EU to move
well look I think that it's important
that he's rolled his sleeves up and got
on with negotiation that's what the
labor party was saying for months and
months and months and we finally got
there but it is important that he's
included the unionists within that
dialogue and he should have probably
have done that months and months ago so
that they felt included and of course
there are concerns about the ERG and his
own back benches but notwithstanding
that if he does get a deal then credit
to him because this is hugely important
for the national interests of our
country and for people of Northern
Ireland we want Power sharing to get
back we want storm and to get back and
certainly businesses in the community in
Northern Ireland do not want unnecessary
friction at the border
you mentioned the dep there and the
importance of keeping them on site
um they're pretty clear on this aren't
they they're a unionist party they don't
want Northern Ireland to be treated any
differently to other parts of the United
Kingdom whether that's Cardiff or
Newcastle or London they want Northern
Ireland to be treated in the same way
have they got a point
an island is
is Kingdom so of course they don't want
it treated differently the dup set out
seven tests no doubt they will want to
scrutinize any deal that comes forward
over the coming days and they will make
their judgment on the basis of those
seven tests that set they set out but
it's hugely important that any deal
catches the spirit of the Good Friday
agreement over 30 years just under 4 000
people lost their lives in those
Troubles of course this is a serious
moment and it requires careful heads and
reflection
you know where to put the border for the
reasons that you've mentioned is
arguably you know the biggest unsolvable
problem with brexit unless of course the
whole of the UK rejoins a single Market
I mean you obviously campaigned for
remain if labor get into power do you
think that should be on the table
look it was always the case if we go
back a few years that people were
raising issues of a border that could
emerge between the Republic of Ireland
and Northern Ireland that was Remedy by
not having a border effectively uh in
the South but I visited Derry London
Derry I was at foil Port looking at some
of the issues that arise for business
there they were doing everything they
can to ease any friction and minimize
any sorts of Customs checks but there
was always more to build on that's why
we look forward to seeing the detail of
this deal as it's emerged that's why
it's important that all sides are able
to consider that carefully there should
be no rush I think on any vote in
Parliament people are entitled to look
at the small print in detail but I hope
now that all of us can come together to
vote through any deal and get back to
Stormont
underpinned by The Good Friday agreement
and move on from this episode that has
now gone on for many years indeed
it was nice and side steps I know of
course that you were one of the
politicians who had concerns about where
to put a border before the brexit vote
that's one of the reasons why you
campaigned for remain but the question
is looking forward do you think it
should be on the table that the UK
rejoins a single Market if labor was in
power
look I think that most of your viewers
will not want to go back to the ranker
and the divisions uh that dominated this
country after that referendum vote uh
the truth is that when you speak to the
European Union when you visit
capitals people want a warm and friendly
relationship between the United Kingdom
and Europe I'm afraid because of the
issues that have risen over the Northern
Ireland protocol we've not been able to
make progress with our European partners
and we've got a government where we had
a former prime minister as trust
describe president macron as a foe or an
enemy we need to get back to structured
dialogue with the European Union so we
can discuss the challenges ahead of us I
think we need to make progress on
Horizon on mobility issues for our young
people and students and we can deal with
issues of qualifications and touring
artists those sorts of issues and of
course we've got the review of the trade
agreement that we struck with them in
2025 so there's much to do but going
back into the European Union it's
absolutely clear that we roll out the
single Market we will out the Customs
Union and frankly we're going to have a
lot to do if we form a government at the
end of 2024. okay understood
um now I spoke to Bernie Sanders this
week we'll hear the interview a little
bit later in the program he said that he
would like to see leaders like Joe Biden
and kirst armor be a bit more radical
because he doesn't accept that in
politics you'll win from the center and
he also said that Labor's NHS plan to
use some spare capacity in the private
sector makes them a bit nervous do you
think he's got a point on any of that
look I think that the missions that were
set out this week are just that
ambitious plan uh wanting to have growth
the highest growth in the G7 comparably
is ambitious what it means is jobs it
means that we can get past the cost of
living crisis that people are
experiencing a clean energy power by
2030 gets us into the Super League where
we need to be it benefits all businesses
across our country and of course people
when you knock on their doors they're
raising issues around safer streets
they're raising issues around our young
people and the opportunities that are
available to them and of course the
Health Service all of these things need
attending to it lives up to our
inheritance the inheritance of Clement
Atlee after the second world war Howard
Wilson that was dealing with the white
heat of technology and reforming all
sorts of issues across our country it's
an ambitious plan we'll set out further
details in the area of Health crime
particularly in education over the
coming months but at the next general
election there will be a clear dividing
line hope Vision ambition from the labor
party and people will look at what the
Tories have achieved over the last 13
years and I'm sorry but it's hard to
point to anything
okay two very quick questions to squeeze
in um firstly you're calling for the
Wagner group the Russia militia Army to
be classified as a terrorist
organization explain why
this is a terrible terrible militia
causing havoc in Ukraine and a loss of
life closely attached to Vladimir Putin
they're also acting in places like Syria
and the Horn of Africa of course we
shouldn't just sanction them we should
prescribe them as a terrorist
organization right across the house
people have been raising issues and
that's why I'm calling along with a vet
Cooper for the Wagner group to be
prescribed today
okay and very very quickly because I
know you need to go Dominic Robb
announcing today transgender women
who've committed violent or sexual
offenses can't be housed in mainstream
women's prisons is that the right policy
look I think that this is a sensitive
issue but clearly someone born uh a male
a man who uh is a predator or who is
violent towards women has to be assessed
appropriately and should not be in a
woman's prison I've spent many years
with an interest in Justice and Justice
issues in the House of Commons women's
prisons are very very uh difficult
places with lots of vulnerable prisoners
but equally there are trans women who
are vulnerable so it's important that
you make the right evidence-based risk
assessment as to the appropriate place
for that prisoner to be okay thank you
very much indeed for being on the show
David let me there
thank you
David Lammy uh there and Dominic rail
we've also heard from this morning on
Sophie Ridge on Sunday it does feel
doesn't it like that brexit deal is a
matter of days away but will there be a
vote to have say after speaking uh to
Dominic Rob I wasn't exactly convinced
that that would happen coming up on the
program at this morning we are going to
be talking to the conservative MP and
share the very influential ERG group of
euroskeptics Mark Francois there he is
and we'll also be hearing from the U.S
senator and former presidential
candidate Bernie Sanders I was just
mentioning that interview in the chat
that had with David Lammy but let's get
a bit of immediate reaction too from our
Deputy Francisco editor Sam Coates will
be talking to him later for his uh big
take on what on Earth is going on with
brexit
[Music]
now will they won't they a deal over the
Northern Ireland protocol has seemed to
get closer further away they closer
again over the last uh 10 days
keeping a low profile Rishi sunak
slipped in and out of Northern Ireland
quietly we have not got a deal yet
that's why the both the foreign
secretary and I but also the Secretary
of State for Northern Ireland will
continue talking to the European Union
Rishi sunak also met with the other four
main parties for 15 minutes each this
morning
it's very much game on and we're very
heartened by that we're very very
conscious that a deal can be done should
now be concluded speedily we hope that
that will be the case there will be
further discussions between the UK
government and the European Union but I
think it is safe to say that progress
has been made the foreign secretary
James cleverley has been in Brussels
European commission vice president Maro
ceskovic said they had a constructive
meeting this burst of diplomatic
activity a signal this journey of
negotiation could soon be over
and will he assure me that he will
address these fundamental constitutional
issues the basis of this deal has been
agreed for weeks but it's the same old
Story the country has to wait while he
plucks up the courage to take home the
malcontents The Reckless the Wreckers on
his own benches
well this Sunday morning it seems like
that could be within sight many expect
it could come as soon as tomorrow but
just how will Euro Skeptics in his own
party react to If you see next deal how
much trouble could they cause if they
don't like it well we're joined now by
the chair of the ERG group of
conservative MPS Mark Francois um
firstly you should say you've got a very
important role in this with the chair of
the group that you represent you're a
skeptic conservatives now we haven't
seen the deal no you haven't seen the
deal no we've got a few link details
what would you make of what would you
know so far well just quickly the
context this is all about upholding The
Good Friday agreement that's what
everyone is trying to achieve that's
been the Bedrock of Peace in Northern
Ireland for a quarter of a century and
the Prime Minister writing in the Sunday
Times this morning said quite rightly
that the protocol has now unbalanced The
Good Friday agreement the late Lord
Trimble a noble Laureate he's the man
that helped create the Good Friday
agreement with John Hume so in May 2022
a few months before he sadly died that
he and John human made great sacrifices
to bring peace to Northern Ireland and
that was now all at risk so this has to
be solved so that we can uphold The Good
Friday agreement that is the that's the
imperative
and in order to do that we have to get a
deal that both nationalists and
unionists feel comfortable with because
the fundamental underlying principle
that runs throughout the Good Friday
agreement like a golden thread is the
principle of consent so that feels
important
the main unionist party are you
effectively saying that if they don't
support the deal you're not going to
support it either well the government is
saying that the foreign secretary said
on Friday that
um the government would not sign off on
any protocol deal without the dups
backing so that's James cleverley saying
that and I think that's just a practical
reality
because if the dup don't consent to the
deal then it's simply not going to fly
and that's been absolutely obvious right
from the word go now the dupr friends
and allies of ourselves and the European
research group we admire them why
when a lot of these people went into
politics you know some decades ago they
did that knowing that their lives might
be under threat from the provisional Ira
one of the most ruthless terrorist
organizations in the world I mean so
none of your viewers I'm sure had to
look under their car before they went to
work in the week but the people in the
dup had to do that every day for many
years but they went to work anyway so
the point is these people won't be
bullied by anybody they will make their
own decision on whether or not or not
it's right to agree to the deal and to
re-enter Stormont we know don't we what
they're going to say because
they said it are pmqs they said that
we're not going to back a deal if the
European courts of Justice have any
oversight over it which we know
effectively that they will and also that
the text itself has to be Rewritten
that's also not going to happen so the
DP aren't going to well well the dup are
more than capable of speaking for
themselves they are not shrinking
violence but we can read between the
lines of what they're saying well to me
it doesn't feel like they're going about
the deal they have been frighteningly
consistent including to us that they
their bottom line is they absolutely
cannot accept a deal that means EU law
is still Superior to UK law in Northern
Ireland if there's no EU law in Northern
Ireland that there's nothing for the
European court of justice to adjudicate
upon now we don't know what is in this
deal we haven't seen the legal text why
does that matter because if you're
talking about altering protocols or
treaties that always comes down to a
definite active legal text
they've made very plain that they would
not sign up to anything until they've
read the legal text I mean we are we're
in the same position what MP worth their
assault would vote for something without
having read it so unless that legal text
when we see it expunges EU law from
Northern Ireland I think it's very
unlikely that the dup will support it in
which case the whole process won't work
I want to talk a bit more about how you
believe you've been treated or let into
the process uh in a moment but just
talking about that EU law we heard from
Dominic Raab he said look if we make the
trade easier then that will mean that
there will be less of a role for the
less of a role is not enough so that's
not enough no no just just putting a
couple of you know intermediate phases
in
in a situation where you still end up
with the European court of justice is
effectively sophistry I mean we're not
stupid
what we want is a situation where EU law
is expunged from Northern Ireland so it
is treated on the same basis as England
Scotland and Wales so any role for the
ecj at all
you're not back yet well it does it
we've left the European Union it doesn't
have that role now in England or in
Scotland or in Wales so if we're going
to treat Northern Ireland as an integral
part of the United Kingdom then we have
to get rid of EU law in Northern Ireland
we've been absolutely consistent on this
so In fairness to them have the dup and
sometimes we feel like how many more
times do we have to tell the government
but I think what's really interesting is
the foreign secretaries
certainly twig this and that's why he
said that the government wouldn't sign
up to anything that didn't have the dups
backing that to me is just an acceptance
of practical political reality when were
you first
asked your opinion when was the ERG
first consulted about this well we've
had meetings with you know with the
government ongoing for for a number of
months on this but what we still haven't
seen is a legal text and I'm sorry to
press the matter but as I hope I've
managed to explain you know when you're
talking about protocols and treaties the
wording matters now interestingly when
you look at the wording of the Good
Friday agreement and this is a point
that a lot of people don't appreciate
sorry the wording of the protocol
actually it hasn't is a clause called
Clause 13 8. and what that says is any
subsequent agreement between the union
and the United Kingdom shall indicate
the parts of this protocol which it
supersedes which it goes on to say can
be done in a whole or in part so the
protocol contained within it the seeds
for it to be replaced it was always
meant to be a temporary Arrangement
whereas the Good Friday agreement was
meant to be permanent so with it using
13 8 you can amend or even get rid of
the protocol if you can come up with a
better way of doing this and for two
years we consistently advocated a
different system which is known as
Mutual enforcement
do you feel like there's been a bit of
political naivety from the government on
this you know you haven't seen the legal
text they haven't brought the dep on the
side the reports in the papers this
morning that there was a bit of a
disagreement should we say between Rishi
sunak and the dep when they went to
Northern Ireland do you think they've
gone away you know they've done the
homework they've answered the essay
question the way that they think they've
wanted to but they haven't done the
political well I think it was someone in
the dup who a couple of days ago said
that this is or in terms this is a very
odd way of going about it we're the
people they ultimately need to convince
and they haven't even shown us the text
so at some point they're going to have
to fess up this text and then members of
parliament are going to want to you know
go through it in fine detail and decide
whether or not to support it I'm in the
unusual position this morning of
agreeing with David Lammy in that he
just said on your program a few minutes
ago Parliament should not be rushed I
mean if I were advising the Prime
Minister my honest advice to him would
be don't try and bounce Parliament next
week because that is likely to go badly
wrong if you look at all the history of
this which is complex
trying to bounce Parliament usually ends
badly so if they do want if they've got
a deal they're proud of show us the text
let us run it by our lawyers let us
fully understand what it means and then
at that point we might be ready to vote
on it but it would be a very bad idea
you say that you're talking about a boat
there yeah there might not even be
available well if you look if you're
going to make any meaningful changes to
the protocol
you're going to have to have a bill so
that's going to mean at some point
you're going to have to have a vote I
think given all the history of this for
the government to try and bludgeon this
through the House of Commons without a
vote of any kind would be incredibly
unwise and I say that as someone who was
years ago a senior with myself
position is already pretty precarious
right the polls the
appalling for the conservatives you've
got to divide a party
if this goes wrong for originally can't
get it through do you think that's the
beginning of the end look we want the
prime minister to succeed we want him to
come up with a deal that everybody can
support
so but in order to do that it's going to
have to be a deal that gets rid of you
look let me try and put it like this
ultimately this isn't about red Lanes or
green Lanes or cycle Lanes it's about
who governs it's about whose law is
Sovereign in Northern Ireland legally
whose writ runs
and we need in order to solve this
problem and to uphold The Good Friday
agreement and to stop us going backwards
in Northern Ireland which absolutely
nobody wants to see we need to get rid
of EU law in Northern Ireland and that's
what our negotiators have got to press
for and if they can't get it then we
need to use the northern line and
protocol bill which is currently stalled
in the Lords in order to achieve that
aim we've got the protocol Bill there
ready to go it it flew through the
columns it's stuck in the Lords and if
the Lords we should reintroduce it and
if the Lord's trying to gut the bill we
should Parliament tax it okay thank you
very much for being on the program this
morning thank you for having me on
well as usual the tape will follow this
program the chance to analyze our
interviews talks through some of the
news lines with their Deputy political
editor Sam Coates always useful
particularly I think when it comes to
brexit but let's get a quick take from
Sam now shall we
blimey
um it doesn't look like it's going to be
plain sailing for any uh brexit Bill
does it
I think uh well there you have it from
Mark Francois unless EU law is in his
word expunged from Northern Ireland in
other words that key element of the deal
that Boris Johnson struck in 2019 that
Northern Ireland would have to stay
within EU rules in order to avoid that
hard border that could become a target
for terrorists unless that happened the
ERG European research group that caucus
of brexiteers within the Tory party will
not back it so it's going to be a rough
ride for Richard Cena when he brings
back this bill potentially tomorrow the
question is how rough and to be honest
Sophie we really can't tell if Richie
sunax brexit deal is put to a vote it
will pass because as David Lemmy made
clear labor will give it its backing
whether there's a vote or whether MPS
find other ways of forcing it uh to a
vote in the House of Commons it will
pass however having 20 30 40 or 50 Tory
MPS Furious that essentially what what
he's done is to cement EU law into
Northern Ireland in perpetuity sure it's
been scaled back but it's still there
that could cause a rage and and nobody
knows where this will end it's worth
pointing out it only takes 37 Tory MPS
to vote with the opposition to defeat
the government uh even to bring it down
it's not very many and there are quite a
lot that across uh well we'll have more
from Sam uh at 9 30 for the take a bit
more of an extended analysis from him
but in the meantime thank you very much
go get yourself a cup of tea you might
be feeling slightly brexit brexit out by
this stage so let's talk uh Scotland
shall win because Nicholas sturgeon has
dominated Scottish politics for the best
part of a decade in which she was
arguably the UK's most successful
politician although of course she didn't
get what her ultimate aim was Scottish
independence her recent resonation means
a leadership contest and a debate about
how her success at War try for that
Independence prize three candidates are
in the race Kate Forbes whose campaign
so far has been dominated by questions
about her religion plush Ash Regan and
the Scottish Health secretary Hamza
Youssef who joins us now great to have
you on the program you're going to be
the first of the three candidates that
we are going to talk to so what's the
pitch
well very simply I want to do the job
because Scotland needs its independence
now more than ever before given this
Tory cost of living crisis that is
causing so much misery and I believe I
am the person that can lead Scotland to
its independence I have the experience
over a decade in government I can unify
both our party and our movement reach
across the Divide bring more people to
support the cause of Independence and
also I believe I am the person who will
bring policies forward that will ease
that cost of living crisis and help to
grow our economy both go hand in hand
so you you say there that you can bring
more people to your side or Independence
which of course is part of the jigsaw
but the other part is how you actually
get the second referendum in the first
place because the courts of rules you
can't have one without westminster's
permission so what would your plan be
have a referendum anyway or use the next
election as a de facto referendum
well look two things to say first of all
our opponents are desperate for us to be
stuck in some kind of Quagmire of
process I want to be talking about
policy it's very very simple actually
yeah but the process is important if
you're not allowed to referendum yes I
will come I will I will absolutely come
to the process don't worry but if we
build a sustained majority for
Independence not where some polls put us
at 51 some at 49 but a sustained
majority for Independence then those
political obstacles will disappear
Independence will become a political
inevitability so what I've said
yesterday is I will restart re-energize
and grow the yes movement and campaign
from the bottom up to get out there to
tell people and persuade them why we
desperately need our independence in
terms of process you're right I've said
quite publicly I'm not weighted to using
the next general election as a de facto
referendum I want to have a really
honest engaging discussion with our
membership not a one-off special
conference but a series of discussions
to to determine what the path forward as
being no doubt if I am leader of the SNP
every single election including the
general election will be about the issue
of Independence now we're going to play
my interview with Bernie Sanders after
our conversation I just want to read you
what he said on Scottish independence he
said I very much appreciate what the
people of Scotland have done and what
they're fighting for my initial thought
is they want to go their own way they
should be allowed to you could try and
get him on the campaign
but actually Bernie gets it it should be
for the people of Scotland to decide
that's not just actually Bernie Sanders
view if you wanted to come a little bit
closer to home I've heard Mark Drakeford
who is a labor Welsh politician who
doesn't believe in Independence but has
said very unequivocally that it should
be up to the people to decide we have a
mandate and you talk about what is the
preferred route actually the preferred
route would be that Westminster doesn't
deny democracy to Scotland gets around
the table gives the section 30 order so
we can hold that legal referendum just
as we did in 2014 we had two governments
diametrically opposed in the issue
coming together respecting the Mandate
we had and allowing a referendum to take
place they're not doing that they're
denying democracy and that's why I'm
going to ensure that we build the
popular support okay um is it I won't be
doing my job properly to say that some
people would question that mandate uh of
course you uh did win the last election
in Scotland but there hasn't been that
sustained majority impulse supporting
Independence I'm quite Keen to talk I
honestly don't know I honestly don't
know how you could I honestly don't know
how you could question them Andy we have
stood time and time and time again on a
manifestation if we were to win the
election then we would we would have the
Mandate for reference with one election
after election after election including
of course post brexit where we said
Scotland was dragged out of Europe
against its will okay as I said as I
said I wouldn't be doing my job properly
if I didn't put the all-time perspective
across there's other things I'm Keen to
talk to you about in the interview as
well now same-sex marriage has of course
been a big part of this leadership race
with the views of your rival candidate
Kate Forbes coming under scrutiny now
back in 2014 you abstained on the final
vote on Scotland's equal marriage
legislation how would you have voted
no that's not actually true so I voted
at stage one for the bill uh why it
wasn't there at stage three is well
known and it was well known at the time
I had a meeting an avoidable meeting to
try to get a Scottish citizen who was in
Pakistan on blasphemy who had been
attacked on death row tried to get him
back to Scotland there was a series of
meetings that were taking place between
myself and the Pakistani government to
get this individual back home one of
those meetings was doing the stage three
ball but let me be unequivocal about it
if I was there I would have voted for it
that was well known at the time the fact
that this is now being dragged up nine
years later in the midst of an election
contest by some people who are
supporting other candidates I think as
it probably tells you the motivation
behind it anybody can look at my track
record on equality and they can see
where I stand on a number of these
issues yeah you you say don't you that
you feel that's been dragged up the
former Minister Alex Neal says that you
were given cover to skip the votes and
the meeting that you talk about could
have been arranged another time just to
be crystal clear on this do you think
that gay sex is a sin
oh look I've answered this question time
and time and time and time again no
matter how many times Sophie you asked
the question I believe an equal marriage
I believe that people's marriage if they
are gay and they are married that their
marriage is no less if there's no more
inferior is worth less than my marriage
as a heterosexual individual so no I I
don't subscribe to that view I think
it's fine by the way I should say for
people to have
um their own personal faith I don't
think that we should bar anybody from
office for having their personal faith
in fact I look I I'm Muslim I I practice
my faith I'll be fasting in Ramadan in a
few weeks time for example the
difference I have is that I don't use my
faith as the basis for legislating I
don't think that's what people want
their legislators to do they want their
legislators to do what is in the best
interests of the country and and I will
continue that Progressive agenda that
Nicola sturgeon has started and has
built over the over the last eight years
under her first Minister under her
leadership as first Minister I'll
continue to do that and that will help
to grow support for Independence
you say there that you don't allow your
personal faith to impact legislation and
you stay very clearly there that you
think that equal marriage is something
that's important and something that you
fully back the question was do you
believe that gay sex is a sin
no if I can just be clear about that
that's not it's not I just I've been
asked a question about 25 times and I've
answered it the same way 25 times so I I
can't change what's in certain faiths I
can't change what's in scripture while I
can tell you is the approach that I will
take which is that I will not allow
personal faith to be the basis of
legislation okay one more kind of
culture question if you like and then
we're going to get on to your Arena on
health
um another question that I'm sure you
feel that has been asked 25 times in the
leadership race but I'm going to ask it
again it is Isla Bryson the transgender
prisoner convicted of rape is she a man
or a woman
well I think Eileen Bryson is that it if
I'm honest I think they're a dangerous
individual deceptive individual I don't
think they're a true trans women I think
they're trying to play the system for
personal Advantage now what I can't do
Sophie is I can't change law the law
which has been the law for many many
years allows I love Bryson to
self-identify as a as a woman if they
wish I think they're at it I don't think
they're a genuine trans women so I
wouldn't described them in that way what
I would say is we need to be really
careful in this discussion because what
we can't do is roll back the rights for
those trans women the 99.9 who don't
commit any crime who live their lives
like you and I do not interfering in
anybody else's rights what we can't do
is regress uh and and and and decide to
curtail people's rights because of one
despicable individual so no I don't
believe Isla Bryson is truly and
genuinely a trans women
Dominic Robb was on the program this
morning talking about his move to say
that if you are a trans woman convicted
of a sexual crime or a violent crime you
can't be housed in a woman's prison do
you would you like that to apply to
Scotland as well do you back that
oh yes it's got Scottish prison service
recently updated their policy and by the
way they've been dealing with these
issues really well really complex issues
actually for many many years I remember
they were doing that in my team when I
was just a secretary but they've changed
and updated their policy that any
individual uh any man that has a history
of violence against women they shouldn't
be in the female prison estate even
during that kind of risk assessment
period I think that's probably where
some of the challenge existed with the
Isla Bryson case as you mentioned the
individual was never
able to cause any harm to the female
inmate inmates at court and Veil but
they probably shouldn't have been housed
there well the assessment was taking
place now I just want to talk a bit
about your record as health secretary a
e waiting times have gone up a quarter
of patients now waiting over 62 days for
cancer treatment you wanted to recruit
800 more GPS by 2027 but in the last
five years you've only managed 113. now
a panel-based survey for the Sunday
Times today found when asked to Ray
write people's performance as Government
ministers Kate Forbes had an approval
rating of plus 14 Reagan got three and
you got minus 16.
it's not great is it well what what I'd
say is that any health secretary in the
midst of a global pandemic is going to
face the challenges that we're facing up
here in Scotland in fact those long ways
are replicated in whether it's
conservative LED England or whale labor
run Wales so those are common problems
faced right across the UK in fact in
Health Services right across the world
because the global pandemic has been the
biggest shock our NHS has faced in 74
existence but what's different up here
in Scotland well what's different is the
fact that the situation hasn't been made
far worse by nurses and ambulance
drivers going on strike we have avoided
strike action up here in Scotland not by
chance not by Good Fortune but because
I've reached out engaged with our
Treasury and colleagues brought them
round the table they've engaged in good
faith we've managed to compromise where
necessary and I think those are pretty
good skills for any future leader or
indeed any future first minister to have
okay just finally Scotland V France and
Celtic V Rangers both kick up at 3 P.M
what are you going to be watching
nah I'm actually going to be speaking to
activists in Aberdeen so I'm going to
end up missing the game I'm afraid
both of them what a nightmare thank you
very much for being on the program today
much appreciated
thanks
now Bernie Sanders has long defied
conventions in U.S politics proudly
wearing the badge socialist when many
think it's a dirty word and he has given
us a typically outspoken interview today
let's have a quick listen to what the
senator had to say
and now you've written a book called
it's okay to be angry about capitalism
so why are you angry
I'm angry because in my country the
United States we have more income and
wealth inequality
than we've ever had in the history of
our country so the middle class
continues to shrink Working Class People
are struggling to put food on the table
but billionaires are doing phenomenally
well and furthermore we have more
concentration of ownership in sector
after sector whether it's agriculture
media Wall Street Transportation fewer
and fewer large corporations control
what goes on in our country and on top
of that you got a billionaire class in
America that is able to contribute huge
amounts of money into individual
candidates and dominate the political
system so what we're looking at is a
nation which is rapidly becoming an
oligarchy you know we talk about Russia
and Putin's oligarchy well in the United
States we have an oligarchy as well
surely you can't be comparing Putin's
Russia we know we've seen firsthand
what's happening of course I'm not
talking about though that a small number
of people have much too much wealth much
too much economic and political power
that's what I'm talking about do you
think the Democratic president currently
um is really getting a grip on that
I think President Biden has done some
very important things I'm not sure he
gets the credit for that but I think in
the need to take on this oligarchy and
to demand that we have an economy not
different than here in the UK an economy
that works for all in not just the few
have we been doing enough no we have not
um you if you care about inequality
do we need to look at what we do as
consumers as well you know if you care
about inequality is it okay to shop at
Amazon
well I think that's a very good question
I'll let individuals make that answer
but what we should be doing absolutely
in the United States is being much more
vigorous in breaking up monopolies
Amazon is a monopoly not the only one
and what we've seen for many years is
these large corporations become much
larger and we don't have administrations
prepared to stop breaking them up
Biden's people are moving they're moving
a little bit too slowly they are moving
and the other thing I guess is wealth
taxes as well right are we taxing the
wealth in it well you're not in the
States look
there are half a million people in the
United States who are homeless they're
up to 85 million people uninsured or
undertrued we don't have a National
Health Care system and you got
billionaires who have more money than
they can spend in a thousand lifetimes
how many homes do you need
how many islands do you need to own how
many jets do you need to own how many
Yachts do you need to own so I think we
should say enough is enough you are
successful in life you want to go out
you make money good become rich but
there should be a limit you don't need
10 billion dollars you don't need 50
billion dollars is it right that you've
been lobbying Biden to introduce higher
taxes on the super wealthy yes it is and
and what what answer well see what
happens I mean he's moving but not as
far as I would like to see okay and now
you mentioned Healthcare and I know
that's one of the things you're pretty
angry about right here in the UK we're
pretty angry about Healthcare as well
and if you look at our system you know
struggle to get a GP appointment
hundreds of people dying every week
because they can't get ambulances on
time you know some people might be
thinking this system the NHS is
fundamentally broken maybe we should be
looking at an insurance model don't look
at the United States that's exactly the
wrong direction to look at
look at strengthening your own system
what this country did in 1948 was
revolutionary what you said at that
point in the formation of the NHS
Healthcare is a human right whether
you're rich you're poor you have a right
to go to a doctor and not take out your
wallet in the United States the function
of Health Care in America is not to
provide quality care to all it's to make
billions for the insurance companies so
strengthen the NR NHS you need more
money put money into it but don't go the
American route we're trying to get out
of that the labor party in the UK one of
the ways that they're looking at
potentially strengthening the NHS is
more Partnerships with a private sector
using capacity in the private sector I
would be nervous about that I don't know
all the details but it sounds to me like
the wrong direction really you because
of the private sector you think is look
the function of the private sector is
not to provide quality care what the
function of Health Care is not
complicated everybody should be entitled
to the best care the system can provide
uh not to have a system in which
insurance companies make make huge
amounts of money
um interesting another big debate here
in the UK is Wages as well and you know
we've got double digit inflation wages
not keeping up people are going on
strike but the government is saying look
if we give you pay Rises that match
inflation that's just going to stay
completion even more what side of the
debate are you on well are they looking
at demanding as the wealthy to start
paying their fair share of taxes
you know that might be a better
alternative look working people in the
United States and in the UK are
struggling they're struggling with the
cost of housing cost of Education
everything else uh I think working
people nurses uh bus drivers I think
those people deserve decent wages they
need wages that can at least keep up
with inflation and in the states as well
I guess
in the United States we're also seeing a
growth in labor activity more and more
workers are standing up fighting back
striking uh and uh we're trying to
workers are also forming unions which is
a very good thing you know it's
interesting talking to you obviously
brimming with ideas you're obviously
still pretty angry about lots of stuff
well I'm angry in the sense that with
all of the technology out there I mean
take a step back and that's what this
book is about asking people to rethink
things you would think that with all of
the technology out there life would
become easier for people right if I give
you a tool that makes you more
productive you should perhaps be making
more money or working fewer hours does
anyone really think that's how happening
for Working Families it is not and this
issue is going to get only worse with
the explosion of artificial intelligence
and Robotics we got to make sure that
technology works for workers not just
the owners of that technology I mean
with the ideas that you're putting
forward if Jay Biden doesn't run again
would you be tempted for another till to
the presidency at this point we're
thinking that Biden is going to run
again okay not rolling it in or out
there very careful answer
um what do you what do you think I'm
interested in this why do you think in a
difficult time sometimes a really
difficult you've outlined some of the
reasons why it's so difficult for
Working Families
people tend to in recent years
tacked the radical right not the radical
left well I think the demagogues all
over the world take the anger that
people feel people should be angry they
should be angry that they their kids in
many cases are doing worse than they are
going to be doing
they can't afford basic necessities of
life they are angry and what demagogues
say is don't look at the people who
really own the system don't look at the
ruling class don't look at the people
who cause the problems look at
immigrants look at people of color look
at gay people look at people it might be
different than you you're supposed to
hate them let's rally around those
hating those people rather than looking
at those who are really causing the
problems it's interesting I mean we've
seen it in in the UK in the states as
well the states as well of course yeah
certainly
um I guess um what others would say is
look you're coming from the radical left
we've seen what happens I don't think
it's all that radical do you know no
that's interesting
fighting for human rights for economic
rights is it radical to say that every
worker in America or the UK should earn
a living wage is it really radical to
say everybody is entitled to Quality
Health Care Quality education affordable
housing is it really radical to demand
that billionaires start paying their
share of taxes I don't think that's
radical I guess what others would say
though is like look if you want to make
a change you can't just sit from the
sidelines coming up with these ideas
that sound great you've got to win
elections
you haven't won an election in the
states Jeremy corbyn I have won a lot of
Elections I am a United States Senator
that's true for the presidency you're
right I stand corrected but you get
where I'm coming from you have to
compromise you have to win from the
center in order to no I don't accept
that in fact the way real change always
takes place is when millions of people
demand it and then suddenly you have
presidents or prime ministers to say I
think that that's a good idea because
they know that millions of people want
it at the end of the day what struggle
is about is working class people
standing up and demanding Justice and
the people on top will respond to that
do you think that perhaps politicians
from the center I guess some would say
more kind of compromising uh politicians
Joe Biden perhaps a Kia stammer over
here in the UK they need to be a bit
more radical yes you do you'd like them
to read your book and to come up with a
few of those ideas take them on board
now you will forgive me there is one
constitutional issue in the UK that I'm
really interested genuinely to know what
your opinion is on it and that's
Scottish independence look it might be
something that you haven't given much
thought to but over here it's such a
live debate because of course we're
looking for a new leader of the Scottish
national party and one of the arguments
is that look Scotland tends to attack
more left politically they've obviously
had a conservative government in
Westminster for over a decade
what's your instinct on it what's your
guts say look I I I'm not an expert on
UK politics I very much appreciate what
the people of Scotland have done what
they're fighting for and my you know
initial thought not being an expert they
want to go their own way they should be
allowed to so you think I should at
least have the opportunity to to that
would seem to me
don't tell anybody I said that don't
worry that's just between us okay don't
worry it won't go anywhere
and finally um because I know you're a
busy man you've you've done countless
interviews over the years including
about your book recently is there ever
you know a question you think I wish
someone had asked me that you think why
why is no one answer me this question
there are a lot of questions in fact one
of the whole chapters on the book is is
dealing with corporate control over the
media all right so in my country I don't
know what it is here it's different here
actually
we have eight major
media
corporate column conglomerates who
control about 90 percent of what the
American people see here in Reed so it's
not just a television network it's owned
by somebody else it's owned by somebody
else who control a lot of the media and
what ends up happening is it's not the
fake news that Trump talks about it's
not that report is lie they don't by and
large
what it is is there are areas that
people do not want to talk about for
example I have no one ever comes up to
me say Bernie what are you going to do
about the grotesque level of income and
wealth inequality nobody says Bernie why
are we spending twice as much on health
care as the people in the UK
and we got 85 million people running
sugar in the church what's wrong with
our health care System
Bernie why is it that we are the only
major country on Earth in the United
States not to guarantee Paid Family and
Medical Leave
there are women in I understand you have
two children right I do all right in the
United States if you have there are
women today giving birth who will have
to go back to work in a week or two in
order to take care of the family they do
not get any paid family leave that is
pretty crazy to me all right so what we
are trying to do is build a movement to
address those inequalities and media
often just will not because they're
owned by very wealthy billionaires and
they don't want to stir things up so I
often don't get the questions that I
think need to be asked not just to me
but other elected officials okay thank
you very much indeed for your time thank
you thank you very much
Dennis unders they're absolutely
brimming with ideas I love the bit when
he said don't tell anyone but I said
this about Scottish independence now a
teacher's union says it will only call
off strikes if there is real progress in
Pay talks but the government says it's
only going to hold formal talks if
strikes are called off so that dispute
like say many seems pretty stuck right
now and of course strikes are due to go
ahead in schools across England this
week with the General Secretary of the
National Education Union Dr Mary balster
joins us now thank you so much uh for
being on the show at your striking next
week which means lots of schools closing
lots of children of course missing out
are on important school days the
education secretary has offered to get
around the table for talks a lot of
parents might be thinking why haven't
you taken her up on it
well she has offered to get around the
table for the talks and that is some
progress and we want to take advantage
of that we want to take her up on our
offer but she put in place an
unacceptable precondition which is that
we stop the strike action before we
start the talks and given that we have
been telling the government
um for over a year now that we are going
to enter a dispute that we've written 18
letters trying to resolve the dispute
and they have just not entered into
negotiations the negotiations we've had
over the last few weeks have been
powerlessly poor with the Secretary of
State saying there's no more money uh we
can't do anything uh then we have to see
some progress so we are willing to
negotiate Anytime Anyplace anywhere but
what we can't do before we have made any
progress in negotiations is call off the
industrial action which is the reason
why we have got to the negotiating table
we don't want to be taking action my
members want to be in classrooms
teaching at pupils this Kobe generation
who have lost so much and we want to be
teaching them but they're also saying we
cannot carry on with the conditions in
school anymore and we can't carry on
with a Workforce which is uh just be
depleted because teachers are leaving
the profession and graduates don't want
to join it and that leaves schools
understaffed and under-resourced and
those are not my words those are the
words of the Chief Inspector Amanda
spielmann we've done a lot in recent
months about school funding and I
absolutely take your points on board
about the pressures that teachers are
under and also the financial pressures
of two on school budgets as well at the
same time though I guess some people
might still be thinking well look I know
you want to have progress before you you
call off the strikes but why don't you
just swallow this why don't you just
pause the strikes in the hope that you
could get a deal I mean that's what the
government did with nurses right they
pulled strikes for talks yeah well the
it's we're not in the same position as
the nurses unfortunately because what
happened with them was there was a joint
press release between the Royal College
of Nursing and the government saying
that the RCM we're going to pause the
strikes in in in favor of serious
negotiations now if I were General
Secretary Pat Cullen of the RCN I would
not have signed that statement unless I
knew in advance what the scope of the
negotiations were what the money
available was us to invest in the Health
Service invest in nurses pay in other
words a huge amount of ground work had
been done to give the General Secretary
of the RCN the confidence in order to
pause the action none of that has been
made available to the National Education
Union and it's a huge thing to ask the
union to stop action which has got the
government to the table where the
government is only saying we'll enter
into negotiations and we have no idea
what those negotiations will Encompass
so I say again to the government we are
ready and willing to negotiate Anytime
Anyplace anywhere stop the silly
precondition which we can't agree to
because we have no idea what you mean by
serious negotiations why don't you just
sit around the table and get into
negotiation and the sooner you do that
the sooner we can stop the strikes and
that's what we want to do
how would you describe the talk so far
with the education secretary they've
been productive if you've been
encouraged by any of it
well I was talking last week to a senior
government official who will remain
nameless who said the talk so far had
been silly
silly
yeah silly and just the reiteration that
there's no more money available this
year that we have to fly to inflation
even though public sector wages aren't
driving inflation and just so they
um that you know there was none of the
information and none of the uh
statements that more money would be made
available in order to base serious
negotiation now I am very pleased that
the government has said that he now
wants to enter into serious negotiations
so let's do that let's drop the three
condition which we can't we can't accept
that we will pause industrial action
which we are taking reluctantly but
which has got us to this stage where the
government says it wants to enter
negotiations it can't do that if we
don't know what on what grounds they're
prepared to negotiate they have to give
us a lot more and they have to start
entering the negotiations because I have
to say at the moment trust is not in
abundance with this government about
their intentions or their um uh that
that view about how this dispute can be
settled it will only be built if we get
around the table so stop the
precondition get around the table and
let's get negotiating at the same time
though people in the government will say
look hang on a minute you know education
was given an additional 2.3 billion
pounds in the Autumn statement that
that's a bigger uh rise than you know
lots of other government departments and
a time when we know that we're currently
spending more in debt than we are on the
whole of the school's budget you're
asking for an above inflation pay rise
you know is that really realistic
well we're going to negotiate I mean
that's our starting position we will
negotiate we want a good pay rise for
teachers because
you know what is realistic I I just
listened to your interview with Bernie
Sanders uh what's realistic about
schools running out of teachers one in
eight math lessons not being taught by
especially there's one in the quarter
physics lessons the government missing
its secondary teacher training Targets
this year by 41 schools are running out
of teachers now this country is not
going to grow it's not going to be
prosperous if we starve our education
service and the government did put 2.3
billion in but next year schools will
still in real terms uh only be seeing uh
their funding levels that they saw in
2010 and that statement by Rishi Stuart
two years ago that he was going to
restore funding Levels by 2025 to those
in 2010 was made before the current
round of inflation that 2.3 billion was
necessary just to keep schools open and
running it is not schools are still
staffed of phones and you don't grow the
economy and you don't have a successful
economy if you don't invest in education
and you know when the government says
will invest in your education when we
can afford to that's no good for this
generation of children as a society and
as a nation children as they go through
school whenever they go through school
deserve to be taught by teachers
qualified in the subject that they're
teaching deserve to learn in buildings
which are not in danger of falling down
and deserve to receive the support they
need in order to learn I don't think
like Bernie Sanders said that any of
these things are outrageous or radical I
think they're the essentials of a
democratic and decent Society
okay we are out of time Dr Mary bow said
thank you very much for being on the
program at this morning
thank you
now you might have noticed but it has
been an absolutely packed show this
morning we've been zipping through uh
guests topics and we're going to keep
zipping on because we're going to go
straight to the take this morning we're
going to rip up at the usual schedule
we're going to go straight to the tape
we're going to bring salmon and we are
going to try and decompress until at 10
o'clock to try and work out what we have
learned because actually I feel like
we've learned quite a lot and it's not
going to be great news I think for
number 10 if anyone's watching I think
do you feel that there might be a bit of
nervousness I guess about how this
brexit deal is going to go down
yeah you just said if anyone's watching
I I just think I ought to make the point
Sophie you've just been talking about
the strikes in schools that are going to
be taking place next week and actually
there aren't going to be millions of
parents sitting around worrying about
Rishi sunax brexit deal this Sunday
morning are there they're going to be
working out what on Earth they do with
their child when their boss wants them
in work and their school can't have them
in the school premises that is the kind
of issue that is concerning breakfast
tables around the UK but it's not the
kind of issue that is obsessing Downing
Street this morning because we are
probably just hours maybe a day or so
away from Richie sunac launching
possibly the biggest gamble of his time
as prime minister this negotiation that
he and his negotiators have been
hammering out with Brussels over what to
do about Northern Ireland uh uh and the
problems that have been left behind by
Boris Johnson's Brett exit deal he
thinks he's got a pretty decent kind of
compromise arrangement with Brussels
that'll sort out some of the problems to
do with particularly checks with Goods
that have been sort of gumming up trade
particularly from Great Britain uh to
Northern Ireland and dealing with some
of the issues uh that the unionist
community have raised when it comes to
Northern Ireland but what in fact he's
doing he's probably helping the
situation but also picking yet another
fight a prime minister a conservative
prime minister picking yet another
enormous fight with a minority of his
MPS over brexit and we don't know how
it's going to end so um slightly wearily
that's where we are this Sunday morning
on the cusp but probably another big
breast up brexit bus stop in the Tory
party watch what you say there uh Sarah
on a Sunday morning here
um I have to say that did cross my mind
as well right it feels like we're Back
to the Future we're having another big
brexit lost up speaking very carefully
um you know we're speaking very
carefully and you know it why is he
doing this it's not one of his
priorities that he laid out in the big
speech at the end of the year you made a
very good point that you know lots of
people watching this morning going to be
primarily worried about strikes getting
their children to school inflation the
economy the state of the NHS that we
touched upon with Bernie Sanders as well
does he need to do this
okay I think the question wisd is really
really good one and really important one
what he would say to on camera what he
would say to you if you were uh if you
if he allowed you to interview him would
be I'm doing it because it's the right
thing to do because there are problems
with the brexit deal in Northern Ireland
and they need to be solved right but in
fact lying behind that he has a couple
of additional motives now the first
reason for doing it is because as people
in Northern Ireland know only too well
there isn't a government there there
isn't an executive storm has collapsed
it's been collapsed ever since the last
round of Elections that put Shin Fein in
first place as a first Minister uh if
the Northern Ireland government would
ever reform him that um uh effectively
uh the dup would uh have the deputy
first Minister job but there is no
government and one of the reasons for
trying to sort out the problems in
Northern Ireland is because the dup
cited those issues as one of the reasons
that they're not going back into storm
on so when he started this task getting
the Northern Ireland government back up
and running was a key goal now the bad
news is Sophie that whatever he does it
looks like he's not going to achieve
that end he's not going to get the
Northern Ireland government up and
running because it does look very likely
as if the dup will reject the deal
because it doesn't go far enough and
therefore won't go back into Power
sharing in Northern Ireland and there
won't be a government so it looks as if
one of the two big aims of his deal is
going to fail so why he's why is he
pressing ahead well that's because he
Richard Cena has a second AIM now he's
not explicitly saying this but this is
what we understand behind the scenes he
basically wants to dramatically improve
relations particularly with the European
Union after years of turmoil under
Theresa May and under Boris Johnson and
under uh Liz trust he wants to as it
were regularized normalize relations
with the EU so he can get on and start
solving other problems like one of those
issues in the list of five priorities
which is dealing with small boats he's
hoping that if he gets on better with EU
leaders then he is going to be able for
instance to do a much stronger deal with
President macron of France uh in order
to deal with the issue of small boats
they could be a meeting in a matter of a
fortnight or so with president macron
but that would only take place if Richie
sunac is pressing go on the brexit deal
that he's negotiated with the European
union now the problem with all of this
is that not only do a significant
minority of his uh back benchers think
that he's going about it the wrong way
when it comes to how he's negotiated it
he thinks they think there should be
much more of a threat to unilaterally
rip up the treaty rather than
negotiating but they also think that
there's an alternative route to dealing
with the small boats issue they think
that as a minority of Tory MPS think
that we should for instance pull out of
the European conventional human rights
or uh at least uh imposed legislative
past legislation uh that would breach
that in order to be much more Draconian
dealing with people coming across the
channel so I I think there's no settled
will in the Tory party about how to deal
with so many of the biggest issues in
the country at the moment Rishi sinak is
on one side of the party on quite a lot
of things but there's a significant
minority who take a different position
on a whole complex web of things meaning
that this route about the protocol is
one thing but we're likely to Tumble
into a whole series of disagreements in
the coming days and weeks that are
related but not specifically the same
and that's just going to be really
painful as well
uh painful I think her is the word um
let's remind ourselves shall we a little
bit of what dominant Robb the Justice
secretary told us this morning I asked
him if he's hopeful with good news on a
brexit deal soon
we're not there yet
um but we're obviously in a position
where uh we're close to on the cusp of a
deal and I think if we can get that deal
over the line it will be you think you
can are you confident I'm reasonably
confident we won't be talking about it
if we didn't think that there was a good
momentum uh some pragmatism that we
haven't seen before from the EU side but
we've got to get all the pieces in place
but it would Mark A a great deal for
Northern Ireland would protect the
Integrity of the United Kingdom
so brexit deal in days according to uh
Dominic Robb Monday it is the day that
we're perhaps hearing of course no
official confirmation of that and then
of course the next question I think is
whether or not there's going to be a
vote on it at all and Sam the other uh
newsline I thought we got from that
Dominic Robb interview as well was the
fact that he said that he would resign
if bullying complaints against him were
upheld I think that's the first time I
said that
it is that's a that's a significant
moment and whilst he initially started
the interview not wanting to be dragged
into the detail of what's being
discussed or or the outcomes I mean I
think he just accepted what would be a
political evidence ability but
nevertheless generates a headline which
is that if there's a bullying complaint
uh upheld against him he would quit
partly because uh he would be asked to
do so by the prime minister in his
position would be untenable uh which
just brings back into the headlines one
of the many other problems that um
Richardson has with the top tier of his
cabinet Dominic Raab is Deputy Prime
Minister he could have to quit so when a
breatherman Home Secretary well where's
she going to be she's a noted brexiteer
how's she going to respond to the brexit
deal and James cleverly well some
indications he's not happy with the
brexit deal either all complicated the
whole top team a bit unstable not a
great place but we should see that to
enter the week and also keep your phone
needed Sam because it feels like we
might be getting news out of that brexit
deal uh see no weekend for you thanks
for watching at Safeway bridge on Sunday
this morning we'll see you next week
[Music]
foreign